welcome to the show everybody welcome
especially to any marchers who might be
listening as the March for Life happens
in DC today I've told you before the
thing that I love about the March for
Life the most is that the March
participants are you know not they don't
stand to gain anything from this their
motivations are not selfish because it's
their demands are not self-serving every
single person hundreds of thousands of
people there right now in DC marching in
place of somebody else
now the women's March four-bike by
contrast which happened last week and so
many others of its types have been
mostly about people saying you know do
such-and-such for me
give me something help me me me me me
but the March for Life is different
March flyff says do this for them give
them a chance give them their rights
then them them them turning the focus
away from the individual and to those
people those human beings who are being
victimized and the those human beings
the them in this case of course are
unborn children now whereas the people
at the so called women's March say
forget about them let them die people at
the March for Life say remember them let
them live that's the those are the two
contrasting competing points of view on
this issue and it's a very stark
dividing line in our culture because the
question is asked and must be answered
should these children be given a chance
or not and however you answer that
question we'll decide what side of the
line you belong on should they be given
a chance or not should they be given a
chance to live or not
now our culture of course has answered
no for the past nearly 50 years the
feminist movement liberalism the media
Democrat Party academia all of these
powerful voices and forces have joined
together in shouting no give them no
chance give them nothing take everything
from them take their dignity take their
rights take their lives and when they're
dead don't stop taking
take some more take their limbs their
livers their brains their hearts carve
them up make make use of their parts
take it all because they're nothing to
us they are they are insects in fact
they are lower than insects because we
would sooner acknowledge the life of an
insect than we would the life of a human
child in the womb they are dirt to us
let them die and then pick apart their
carcasses and throw the rest in the
dumpster that has been the answer from
our culture people at the March flight
from the pro-life movement instead of
saying no give them no chance the answer
is different it's a yes it is a rather
you know the message and the answer from
the pro-life movement is is rather
elegant in its simplicity and forceful
and compelling because of that
simplicity every child should be given a
chance to live yes we affirm the life of
every human being at every stage of
development in the womb and outside of
it at the beginning of life and at the
end of it yes a child is entitled to
live the life that they have been given
yes a child is according to our
country's own founding documents endowed
by God with an inherent human dignity
that no one on earth not even his own
parents can deny him a child's existence
may indeed require sacrifice on our part
it may it may feel burdensome at times
to care for people who cannot care for
themselves but that does not give us the
right to dispose of these people like
old scrap metal our children have the
right to live and so it is our
responsibility to care for them to give
them our time or energy our money our
love and a civilized society should
recognize that obligation and enforce it
by law just as we do with children
outside the womb we say to parents you
have an obligation you have a
responsibility to those children you
can't neglect them you can't just toss
them to the side you can't just leave
them in the house and go do your thing
you have a responsibility to them
doesn't matter if it's hard because a
matter if it requires sacrifice you have
to do it because that you they are your
children and that's you are the parent
if I bring a child into this world it's
my fundamental duty to tend to that
child to make whatever sacrifices that
entails and if I cannot or will not then
it's my obligation to find somebody who
will but one thing that I cannot do is
just kill the child
that's it that's the mandible
says and everybody the march of life
what they say is well you know that's
our message to parents of born children
so why would it not be our message to
the parents of unborn children
a very simple thing
to kill people because their existence
interferes with your own that is one of
the most basic and fundamental moral
principles known to men or at least it
used to be
[Music]
the message as I said very simple now as
we continue with the show let's check in
with Duke Kannan yeah I like Duke
cannons approach because their point is
listen it's hard to improve yourself
self improvement is very hard so set
modest goals don't go all crazy trying
to transform yourself in one fell swoop
most resolutions don't last anyway
mostly because dramatic self improvement
is hard that's why Duke Canon Supply
Company wants you to consider lowering
your expectations that's that's an easy
thing to do well you know we can all
accommodate that lower your expectations
this year with the moderate
self-improvement box I have one myself
right now it's a one step program to
achieving a slightly better version of
yourself this box is packed with over
eighty dollars of premium american-made
grooming goods designed to help you look
and smell just a little bit better in
2020 moderate self-improvement usually
84 dollars now it's 50 dollars for a
limited time some of its some of the
stuff in there includes the trench
warfare dry ice body power powder I
should say body power as well but
perhaps trench warfare antiperspirant
and deodorant the news anchor 2 and one
hair wash the working man's face wash
and then my favorite they've got the
big-ass brick of soap and also the
big-ass brick of soap jr. for the
slightly for the slightly smaller size
this one-time offer it's not a
subscription box it's just fifty dollars
with free shipping to the lower 48
states all products are tested for
quality and endurance by active duty
military and five percent of net profits
are donated to causes benefiting
veterans and active duty military visit
Duke cannon comm and use the promo code
Walsh for 15% off your entire order
that's Duke cannon dot-com promo code
Walsh alright I love this someone I want
someone to give this man a medal this
man deserves a medal here's a voter
confronting Elizabeth Warren about her
student loan forgiveness plan and I love
everything that he has to say listen to
this
[Music]
he made more 90 but I work a double
shift work next to my daughter she is 10
so we did the right thing so it might
have been a little hard to hear over the
din of the of the crowd noise what he
was saying is that he paid for his
daughter's college he worked a double
double shift he made a lot of sacrifices
and he wants to know if he's gonna get
his money back under her plan and her
answer was I loved her answer answer was
not just know her answer was of course
not of course not
I don't know yeah this isn't about you
we're not trying to help you out no now
as we've been talking about on this show
there is no response to his point
she has no response because there really
isn't one to give there is no morally
coherent rebuttal to his argument he's
saying I'm financially hurting now
because of the sacrifices that I made to
pay for my daughter's college I'm out
that money I've had to do a lot of
things I've had to change my whole
lifestyle around had to work double
shifts and everything to afford you know
sending her to college
am I gonna be made whole will I get
restitution the only thing that a
proponent of loan forgiveness can say
and and and and this is this is what
proponents have been saying about this
guy from what I've seen online the only
answer is hey tough luck deal with it no
you don't get any money you don't get
yeah hey that's your problem quit your
whining you're selfish jerk basically
here's the problem if you can say that
to him if you are a person who wants
loan forgiveness
and your message to this guy is hey
tough luck shut up you don't get your
money back
go cry about it your whiner if that's
your answer to him
why can't that be my answer to you
you see
if that's what you're saying why can't I
throw that right back in your face
why is it tough luck for him and not for
you
why is tough luck such a terrible and
evil thing for me to say to you but you
could say it to him personally look I
mean just from my perspective as someone
who basically doesn't have a dog in this
particular fight because I don't have
student loans and I also didn't pay any
back although I have been paying my
wife's loans back so I do have a dog in
the fight as a matter of fact but still
from my perspective I think that guy is
a much more sympathetic figure than you
are if you're somebody who has loans and
you're clamoring for loan forgiveness
because for the simple fact that he
actually paid back his you know he
fulfilled his financial obligations this
whole is this whole idea was of
forgiveness wasn't his idea he wasn't
the one clamoring for it all he's saying
is hey if we're doing this then what
about me
I just find that to be a much more
sympathetic position to be in as opposed
to somebody who signed on the dotted
line accepted the loans went to college
got the education and then immediately
started crying they don't want to pay
back that that to me is just not very
sympathetic so if you have this harsh
dismissive answer to this guy then I
think that you've opened yourself up to
the same sort of answer and of course we
have the additional problem as we
discussed a few shows ago of people with
other forms of debt why not forgive
theirs so you create all these problems
all these unanswerable questions when
you start picking arbitrary winners and
losers and forgiving some people their
financial obligations but not others so
what's the solution well how about this
this is my solution and this is what I
would say to that guy we forgive
nobody's dead not mine not yours not
anybody's every adult is expected to
settle their debts live with the choices
they made and in the future to stop the
bleeding as I have advocated many times
we start
encouraging better choices and some of
those choices are gonna be like don't go
to college maybe there are a lot of
people in college you don't need to be
there a lot of people with a college
education who don't need it and that's
just insult to injury right when you're
paying back a loan and you're you've got
all this debt and you're not even using
the education and I couldn't I can
understand how frustrating that would be
so the real solution is so we talked
about this yesterday in regards to
something else and somebody was saying
what's the solution well most of the
time in life with these sorts of things
the only solution is people have to make
better choices that really is the only
feasible solution so with college and
student loans everything the only real
solution is just that people stopped
being reckless and foolish
it is reckless and foolish to take on
enormous debt to go to college when you
don't even know what you want to do with
your life and you don't know if you're
gonna use the education now if you do
know what you want to do and you have a
certain plan and you know you need you
had the education in order to achieve
your goals then that's not reckless
that's a risk but it's a calculated
smart risk you want to be an engineer
you want to be a doctor you know you
need the education you take it on
there's a definite risk there but it's
calculated it's smart to take on a
six-figure debt and go to college when
you don't even know what you have no
idea what you want to do with your life
that's stupid
as a stupid reckless thing to do what's
the solution people need to stop doing
stupid and reckless things that's it
thing for if we're talking about
mortgage or people with car loans and if
you find that you know you can't afford
your house what you probably should have
bought a house you can afford that what
else can we say that's the solution all
right I'm speaking of homes let's
check in with our friends over at ring
you know there's nothing worse than
feeling unsafe in your own home if
there's anywhere in the world where you
ought to feel safe it's in your home and
you have a right to that a right to feel
safe and be safe in your home and your
family does too
and that's why I use ring and that's why
you should use ring two rings mission is
to make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or if there's a surprise
visitor you'll get an alert and you'll
be able to see and speak to them no
matter where you are you do it all on
your phone that's thanks to the HD video
and two-way audio features on ring
devices personally it gives me peace of
mind knowing that I can see my house
wherever I am in the world and I know
travel a lot so I can always check in on
my house see what's going on I know that
my house is in a sense Within Reach
all I got to do is reach for my phone
and I can see what's what's happening as
a subscriber you have a special offer
and a ring welcome kit available right
now at ring.com slash Walsh the kit
includes a video doorbell and chime Pro
which is just what you need to start up
to start building a ring of security
around your house today go to ring.com
slash Walsh
that's ring.com slash Walsh ok I wanted
to talk about this there's a piece on
medium right now that's kind of gone
viral and it's gotten a lot of attention
the title of the article Millennials
love Zillow because they'll never own a
home
yeah I love these millennial woe-is-me
type articles there's a lot of them on
the internet these days and here's one
of them there's a few points I want to
make about this first I'll read a little
bit of this article from Angela
lashbrooke on medium says the apartment
I found on Zillow has cornflower blue
walls and original details with crown
molding still intact a rarity among
today's bleached and flavorless condo
renovations
it has picture windows and a functional
fireplace and it's only a couple blocks
from Prospect Park it isn't perfect the
kitchen is mismatched and hideous and
the second of two bedrooms is minuscule
little more than a walk-in closet with a
window but it's big enough for a small
child and the place is charming well
cared for and modestly sized with
being a grim shoebox it will be perfect
for my husband and me and our dog and
even a kid if we decide to have one I
can envision our bed frame and the
little armchair in the bedroom next to
the window and my favorite of the framed
art we own in the dining room I imagine
how I would renovate the kitchen
replacing the metallic backsplash with
sunny yellow tile but the apartment
costs eight hundred and fifty thousand
dollars not including homeowner
association fees home insurance and
property taxes the total monthly cost
according to Zillow would be four
thousand five hundred and forty six
dollars a 20% down payment would be one
hundred and seventy thousand dollars a
lower down payment while possible would
carry with it mortgage insurance and
likely higher interest despite the
apartments Humble size and middle-class
appearance owning it is an impossibility
a daydream nothing more Millennials are
less likely to buy a home than previous
generations were between the ages of 25
and 39 and it isn't because we don't
want to research shows that we do but as
home ownership becomes less of a reality
and more of an illusion many of us
resort to merely imagining ourselves in
our own homes via the internet websites
like Zillow Street easy and realtor.com
or real estate dedicated Instagram
accounts allow many of us to daydream
about the security and stability that we
could have if we could buy a home
meanwhile we're stuck renting so in a
zones over that goes on for a while okay
you get the point Millennials can't the
poor Millennials can't buy homes they
really want to and this woman has a home
she really loved to buy as you can
because turns out a little bit of a
logistical problem it's eight hundred
and fifty thousand dollars okay so
there's a and this this this article is
resonated with a lot of money let's how
I saw it being shared online and there's
a lot here that frustrates me and I
could and I I approach this as a
millennial and a homeowner I am a
millennial homeowner so let me we do
exist it is not an illusion my house
that I'm in right now is not an illusion
it is a real house so first of all it's
not true
that Millennials can't buy homes or that
most of us never will
owning a house is a very much a feasible
possibility it's just that you see you
might not be able to own the exact house
you want in the exact area you want for
the exact price you want so yes those
houses you're looking at on Zillow the
house shopping you do when you don't
have to worry about silly things like
budget the houses that you find in that
scenario those houses you may never own
it shouldn't be surprising that if you
go on Zillow with no budget and you
start looking at the houses you're gonna
see a lot of really nice houses that
you'd love to own but you can't it's not
surprising that this individual was able
to find a house she really loves for
eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars
I think pretty much anyone can find a
house they love for $850,000
but it's eight hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and most people can't
afford that but that doesn't mean that
you can't afford any house you see
that's my point so we've got
we've got Angela here would love to own
a home and she talks about for the rest
of the article how much you'd love to
own a house in general and how much it
sucks to be renting okay I'm sure you
can find Angela a house on Zillow that
you could afford it's just that it's not
gonna be that it won't be your dream
home it won't be a home that you can
with you know poetically described for
three paragraphs about all the lovely
features it might not be that kind of
home but you could still find a home see
this is what you find a lot in my
generation and I and to me it's it's
it's pretty confounding you hear
Millennials say all the time oh I can't
do that when really they can do it it's
just that they don't want to make the
sacrifices associated with it so when
they say I can't do that what they mean
is I can't do that while maintaining the
level of comfort and luxury that I
prefer that's what they mean or they
mean I can't do that in exactly the
ideal kind of way that I would like to
do it
when someone says I can't move out of my
parents house well you can any adult can
if you're able-bodied and and and
everything especially if you're employed
you can do it but you might not want to
live in the sort of apartment you'd have
to live in if you did move out and you
might not want to work as much as you'd
have to work if you did move out and and
so that's why you're not moving up but
in and that's your choice but just don't
say you can't you can you're choosing
not to and there's a difference
I'm not making any judgments about the
fact that you choose not to well if
you're an adult living at your parents
house eventually you really should move
out and but when it comes to buying a
home yeah that's up to you that's I have
no opinion about whether or not any any
other person buys a home but if you're
sitting here and and and you know you're
gainfully employed and especially if
you're married and your spouse is
gainfully employed you can almost
certainly afford a house as long as your
credit is okay if it's in shambles then
you're you know that might preclude you
for a while but if you've got decent
credit and you've got it and you're
gainfully employed you you can buy a
house it's just that it might not be the
kind of house you want and if you're
going on a website like like Zillow
that's the problem with a website like
Zillow is because you can you know back
in the old days I I assume before they
had the internet and people went to buy
homes yeah there might have been
catalogues and pamphlets you could look
through but it was you didn't have
access to that much so if you were
looking for a home in 1992 you probably
weren't looking at homes in the $850,000
range because they weren't just a click
away
right but now you can and so people look
at these houses and and then they can
you know they could make a look in the
eight hundred fifty thousand dollar
range and and and then they can start
comparing those houses to the houses in
the let's say the $250,000 range which
is what they can afford and the
comparison makes those homes in the 2050
thousand dollar range look terrible and
so they don't want to do it
and then they walk away dejected saying
oh I can't buy a home again
you can it's just not you can't buy that
home or home in that range which doesn't
mean that you can't you know one thing
that you might do one thing we did in
the house that I'm currently living in
is we bought a house
a cheaper house that needed some work
and then we did the work and we
renovated it and now it's you know to me
it's exam not gonna call my dream home
or I don't not sure I even have a dream
home but the home we live in now is
exactly the kind of home I wanted but
when we were shopping for fur houses I
couldn't find exactly the kind of home
and we couldn't find exactly the kind of
home we wanted that was move-in ready
and so we found a cheaper home that had
the potential to be the home we wanted
and we put the work in so you know there
are things you can do but you have to be
willing to make those sacrifices and
kind of adjust a little bit I you know
and I do recommend homeownership for a
few reasons first of all of course
you're getting equity and something
you're not just throwing your money away
I think sometimes about what I spent on
apartments from the age of 20 to 28 when
I was living in apartments and it gives
me heartburn to think about how much
money I spend just throwing down a hole
even when I was even when I was single
and I lived in a dumpy little place it
was only 500 bucks a month I rented but
it looked like a $500 a month apartment
and it and I specifically moved to it to
an area that had those cheap places not
the nicest area but even that lived
there for five years $500 a month wasn't
making a lot of money during that time
and that works out to what like 30 grand
I'm terrible at math so was that if for
five years from I think so
there's a lot of money and I have
nothing to show for it it's just it's
it's gone right whereas with a house you
put the money into it and and you can
always get it out we sold the first
house that we bought you know five years
ago or so we lived in it for three years
we moved hadn't even come close to
paying it down but we sold it and we got
back all the money we put into it plus
extra and you can do that with the house
and that's nice but here's the other
thing that's good about homeownership I
think and buying a home and that process
I think it's a learning process and it's
a growth process and I think there are a
lot of people my generation that that
could could benefit from the process of
buying a home because because buying a
home is all about managing expectations
you you learn a lot about the world you
know and about life and how unfair life
is and how nothing is exactly you know
things that are too good to be true
really are and you're not gonna find the
ideal situation that you're looking for
right there's a difference between the
the reality you conjure in your head in
your dreams in your fantasies and and
reality itself in three dimensions and
you learn stuff like that when you're
buying home and it's an important lesson
to learn and you learn things like if
you're if you are looking on Zillow and
you see a home that is your dream house
and everything looks amazing and it's
affordable what you learn is pretty much
a 100 percent chance when you go to look
at the house they're gonna be massive
problems with it there's a reason
there's a reason why it seems too good
to be true you know we went through that
with our first house that we bought we
saw a house we were doing home when we
were shopping for the home we found a
house that that was very affordable
under our budget on a nice chunk of land
it seemed like big house like way bigger
than we needed but and we thought this
is incredible how is this house so cheap
and then we went to look at it and it
was the house was half built somebody
had been building the house and then
given up and tried to sell it and you
didn't see that part you didn't see the
unfinished the whole unfinished part of
the house and the Zillow pictures and so
you know
it's it's a common thing that you go
through when you're buying houses and
it's clear to me that there are a lot of
Millennials that could use lessons like
that where ultimately yeah you hear
people say I don't want to settle I
don't have to settle in life well you
know then then you're not gonna ever
live a life because life is about
settling I have news for you you're
gonna have to settle when you buy a
house you're gonna be settling you're
not gonna find exactly what you wanted
you're gonna settle they're gonna be
things when you go into the house buying
process there are things that you that
you want that you consider to be
non-negotiable okay I want this out of
the house out of the property so on what
you're gonna find is that you have to
negotiate on some of those and and
you're gonna start paring down what your
non-negotiable things are you start with
a list of like ten things that are
non-negotiable that you absolutely want
in a house in a neighborhood in the
community and you discover you're not
going to find those ten things unless
you strike it rich and win the lottery
so then eventually it whittles down and
you're left with maybe like two things
that are non-negotiable it's an
important process and and one that's
that I think people should go through
all right before we get the emails a
word from policy genius you know life is
unpredictable guys I mean speaking of
making plans and and life decisions and
everything you never know what's gonna
happen
we all have plans for the future for the
next day the day after and so and so on
but you have to be ready for the
unexpected and that has to be a part of
your plan that's why life insurance
exists to account for the
unpredictability of life and that's
where policy genius can help policy
genius makes finding the right life
insurance a breeze in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price you could save fifteen
hundred dollars or more a year by using
policy genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork all the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also can help you find the
right home insurance speaking of buying
homes auto insurance disability
insurance it really is a moral
obligation I think to to be prepared in
this way
to have life insurance to have something
you know for your families should should
the unexpected happen so be prepared for
the unexpected get life insurance it
takes just a few minutes to find your
best price and apply it policy
genius.com policy genius will always get
the future wrong so you better get life
insurance right all right let's go to
emails Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
wall show at gmail.com this is from
Matthew says big fan of the podcast I've
been listening to it for a while now I
have a question for you that would four
what would happen under your regime with
this situation
my soon-to-be wife wanted to invite her
dinner and hug her friend and husband
over for dinner that was my first time
meeting them and wanted to make a good
impression I love cooking and I asked my
fiancee
do they like meatloaf once they answer
the question with yes I started
preparing the dish I used deer meat from
the deer I harvested a month ago i time
it perfectly to be done by the time they
arrived once they arrive and meet my
fiance and I get all the food ready to
serve and I even get some bourbon out
for myself and the husband to enjoy none
for the women ha ha you sexist as we
start eating my fiancee and her friend's
husband tell me how good the meatloaf is
my fiance's friend looks at me and asks
if I have mustard looking at her
confusingly I hand her some mustard out
of the fridge she covers the loaf with
mustard even though I had a special
barbecue sauce I made already on the
dish I was disgusted and still might go
see a therapist under your regime how
would you handle this mustard disaster
first of all mustard on meatloaf is
deranged and this is why under my regime
you're not going to be allowed to just
put any condiment you want on a dish we
got to get control this this has gone
way overboard there have to be some
limits there have to be some limits on
freedom and when I'm in charge there
will be lots of limits on freedom as you
know this is one people cannot be
trusted with their own condiments and so
when I'm in charge there will be a list
of all the approved condiments first of
all all the approved dishes that you may
eat it'll be a generous list you know
probably at least ten items on it and
and then here are the condiments that go
with that dish you don't have to use the
condiments I'm not saying that but I am
saying you cannot use a condiment that's
not approved for that specific dish in
this case it's even more outrageous
because you you made a homemade venison
meatloaf and homemade barbecue sauce and
this person requests a condiment that
was not even provided at the table and
then smothers it all over your beautiful
dish that is that is outrage that is an
outrageous insult just so you know I
mean etiquette here people this is the
same things happen to me so you could
see I'm taking this personally if
somebody prepared now it's worth look if
you get pizza or something you're doing
takeout pizza and you put whatever
condiment you want on it but and you can
request a condiment if you're at
somebody's house and you're ordering
takeout and there's a condiment you want
for the dish and they haven't brought it
out to the table I think in that case
it's okay to say oh do you have XYZ but
if it's a homemade dish and and this is
someone who cares about their cooking
and puts time into it as as our friend
Matthew did first of all eat what's on
your plate and use the condiments that
are at the table to ask for economy that
was not provided is an insult number one
you're ruining the dish number two what
you're saying is this is an inedible to
me I cannot eat this unless unless you
give me this assistance with this other
condiment and
it's insulting so that's you know I just
just so you know why I'm quiet gets so
emotional about this I will never forget
the time when I made chili for a guest
at my house and they put syrup on it
syrup on the chili
that I had made but I had slaved over so
I spent 12 hours making in the slow
cooker all of the flavors and spices
were exactly correct it was the right
balance of everything doesn't need
anything you want to put some cheese on
it fine sour cream okay
syrup you might as well you might as
well just get up and spit in my face
spit directly my face you might as well
it's the same thing all right um this is
from Aaron says dear Matt you argued on
the show that it is morally wrong to
have a massive house because in that
situation the morally right thing to do
would be to give the money to someone
who needs it while I agree that it is
morally right to give the money to the
poor I believe that you presented a
false dichotomy between morally right
and wrong I believe there is a third
option morally permissible for example
in your case with the house I know
someone who gives upwards of 30% of his
income to charity and yet also has an 11
bedroom house the distinction I want to
make is that at a certain point it can
be morally permissible to spend money on
yourself even if it would be morally
right to give it to the poor thanks for
all you do love the show but as a
freedom-loving american i will be forced
to lead the rebellion against your
dictatorship sorry in advance I'm not
sure I agree with you here you're
drawing a distinction between morally
permissible and morally right you're
saying that there could be something
that is morally permissible but is not
morally right so I don't think I agree
with that I think if something is
morally right if something is not
morally right it is morally wrong
another way maybe another term that we
could be using would be morally licit
versus morally illicit and the term and
in that case if something that is
morally licit is both morally
permissible and morally right but to
draw a distinction between right and
permissible I you know I I just don't
know if I agree with that there are
things that are morally neutral so or
are effectively morally neutral so the
color of the shirt I'm wearing a blue
shirt that was a morally neutral
decision there's not a lot of moral
content to the decision of what color
shirt to wear but it wouldn't be
accurate to say that
me wearing a blue shirt is not morally
right but it is morally permissible no
it was a it was a morally right decision
it's just that the moral implications of
my shirt color are so minor as to
essentially be non-existent right so
what I'm saying is that if somebody is
doing a morally permissible thing with
their money it must also be morally
right in that it can't be morally
permissible and morally not right am i
saying that your friend is morally wrong
for buying an 11 bedroom house no I'm
not I I don't I can't make that decision
I'm not I don't know his situation I
mean there are certainly I'm not saying
that there's a you know a certain number
of bedrooms that it's okay to have and
if you go over that number it's morally
wrong or that there's a certain correct
size for that I'm not saying that there
are certainly scenarios where a person
could own a bigger house and there's no
moral problem at all I mean one example
would be you find a good deal on a you
know on a really old house I mean a lot
a lot of the older houses tend to be
bigger and and you know and okay fine
it's a beautiful old house and I don't
think there's there's nothing
overindulgent about that or obscene
about it however there can be situations
where buying an obscenely big house you
know it could be morally wrong it's just
it's I don't think that you can set up
exact parameters and say if you go over
this I think it's a case-by-case basis
and it also has a lot to do with the
intentions and what's in the heart of
the individual but my point yesterday
was simply that obviously there is a
point we could talk about where that
point is but there is a point where a
person could be living in a way that is
greedy materialistic and overindulgent
and if somebody is living that way
that's morally wrong if they're not
then then there's no moral issue and
that's it
all right I have another email a
slightly more contentious email on this
topic to read but before we do you know
if you're a listener to this show you
know and we just talked about it to
start the show the March for Life the
pro-life issue you know how important it
is not just to me but to to to the
country to our culture 60 million
children who have been killed in the
womb and that's what people are marching
for in DC today is to speak up for those
for those for those children but the the
people who are the proponents of killing
babies people on the side of killing
babies and maybe is not so surprising
that they can tend to be vicious and
underhanded and deceptive in their
tactics and if you come out against them
they're gonna they're gonna respond
they're gonna try to they're not just
gonna respond rhetorically with
arguments they're gonna try to destroy
you because whatever it takes to protect
the abortion industry that's where they
that's what they're going to do and we
face that ourselves at the Daily wire
we've had our advertisers our sponsors
targeted we've faced attempts at
censorship and so on because of our
pro-life message but we're not the only
ones you know the group live action is
one of the biggest voices in the
pro-life movement they continue to do
some of the most important work of the
pro-life movement and they have been
banned from advertising on Twitter
they've been banned from Pinterest
altogether they've seen their
advertising efforts on many different
platforms restricted or interfered with
that is why our daily wire.com members
are so important your membership helps
keep our cameras on and our microphones
turned up even when the left pressures
our sponsors that's why from now until
January 31st a portion of any daily
wire.com membership will be donated to
live action if you use the promo code
live action to support awareness and
education around the world on this issue
so join daily wire.com and make your
pro-life voice heard okay this is from
Pamela says dear Matt you completely
misunderstood Brian's email to you first
of all when you're talking about slave
labor
you are implying that it is here in the
United States which it is it is not that
was his point also the exception does
not make the rule are some wealthy
people greedy probably as are some
leeches on society does that make all
poor people greedy no it does not
all your statement does is reinforce the
liberal lie that all wealthy people are
bad and what is immoral about owning
more than one house you are enforcing
the don't waste food there are people
starving in China rhetoric on that note
you also said that life is not fair and
that some black people live in poor
areas and that we don't we wouldn't know
what it's like because of our privilege
I am white and for a period of my
childhood I ate from trash cans we were
so poor we keep the racist we keep the
racist lie alive with nonsense comment
comments like yours you are clearly
trying to play both sides of the issue
don't pick a side it doesn't make you
appear superior or open-minded on the
contrary it makes your opinion appear
weak I realize you have your own style I
try hard to see past that as I do enjoy
the daily wire but you step so far over
the line yesterday and today again I'm
not sure how much longer I can keep
listening and for the record only people
with no self-control eat and drink and
unhealthy levels on cruises plenty of us
work out and limit our alcohol and food
intake thanks Pamela and thank you for
the note at the end there your
self-control is an inspiration to us all
but speaking of misunderstanding the
points good lord
your your email Pamela and I say this
with no offense intended but just one
long list of non sequiturs and Stroman
it is shocking to me then you could have
actually listened to the things I've
been saying the last two days and that's
what you come away with first of all I
never said or implied that companies who
use slave labor are doing it in the US
in fact I specifically said that slave
labor is especially an issue for
companies that that that outsourced
overseas I specifically said that though
I never said that all of them use slave
labor I said some of them have some why
is the word sum so difficult to
comprehend why it's not just you Pamela
why is it hard for people to understand
that the statement such-and-such
sometimes happens is not the same as
such-and-such always happens there are
things that sometimes happen in fact
most things that happen only happen
sometimes so the word sometimes is a
really important word to understand it
is not the same as always
Pamela second for the 10th time I never
said all wealthy people are greedy or
that all wealthy people are bad and I
specifically repudiated that notion in
depth at length I repudiated it I said
some are greedy some some some som II
please look it up some you know
an issue that exists in the world greed
is an issue it's a real issue that's my
point
now if you want to disagree with that
then you have to understand what you're
disagreeing with you are not disagreeing
with my point that all wealthy people
are greedy because that was not my point
that's not the point I made if you're
disagreeing with my point then you are
disagreeing that some wealthy people are
greedy which means what you're claiming
is that no wealthy people are greedy if
you're disagreeing with me that has to
be your claim I also never said it's
immoral to own more than one house never
said that never implied it I also never
brought race into it okay you brought
race into it I didn't I mentioned for
example a kid living in the inner city
with no father surrounded by crime etc I
also mentioned a kid growing up in a
trailer park with a meth-addicted mother
these were two hypothetical examples
that are not just hypothetical because
we know that they exist in the real
world but these were two sort of
standard examples of the kinds of people
who might grow up in a situation that
because of the situation they were born
into it will all but preclude them from
some opportunities now typically the
former example of someone in inner city
that's gonna be a black child typically
the latter will be white so I cover both
bases I didn't turn it into a racial
issue you did I didn't say that all
white people are privileged you
interpreted it that way for some unknown
reason and then you say pick a side what
what the hell are you talking about pick
a side what side pick a side what are
the sides on the complex moral issues of
human greed privilege and poverty that's
what we're talking about here and your
response is pick a side pick a side what
an enormous Lee silly thing to say
Pamela pick a side see your problem is
that and I'm gonna be real with you and
I don't care if you listen or not maybe
you haven't picked up on that by now I
really don't care if me simply saying
that greed is bad offends you to this
degree if you are so allergic to nuance
that you can't even comprehend the words
sometimes Pamela then I'm not sure I can
provide for you the kind of content you
want and I don't think I want to provide
that sort of content so you have to make
your decision your problem and this is
why I'm it frustrates me so much that I
just I am so tired of this I'm so sick
of it you have bought into these
simplistic talking points that you see
on cable news and you see in Facebook
memes and you've bought into them to
such an extent that you literally hear
those talking points even when they're
not being said you hear them it's the
only thing you're capable of hearing
apparently are the talking points you
just accused me of saying a whole bunch
of things I never said you can go back
and look at it's all on tape I said one
thing and in your head you imagine this
whole other conversation that never took
place why because you've been told that
the correct opinions with regard to this
issue are ABC okay so on this issue
which is a very broad very nuanced
complex big topic again greed poverty
privilege you know these sorts of things
but you've boiled that whole topic you
boil it down to a few basic talking
points and what you in your head you
think if we're talking about this you
have to say ABC in any opinion that is
not ABC is wrong and is this it is thus
I guess liberal and so every non ABC
opinion is the opposite it is an XYZ
liberal opinion so even if I'm saying
something else you know maybe I'm not
giving you the ABC talking points maybe
I'm saying LMNOP or something you hear
it as XYZ because you've been told that
that that there are
only a few approved opinions on this
issue and every non approved opinion is
a bad evil liberal opinion and so when I
was treading into this water to talk
about it you were expecting to hear the
standard very very basic shallow normal
right-wing conservative thing right
that's all you were expecting here
that's all you wanted to hear you heard
something else and instead of actually
listening to what I was saying your mind
went I don't know red flag liberal
liberal liberal and then you started
inventing this whole thing that I must
be saying rather than listening rather
than listening what I'm saying in your
head you're just filling in the blanks
oh he's actually saying this he's a
liberal that's what the NEMA fication of
public discourse has done that's what
cable news has done I find it endlessly
depressing and frustrating and I ask
that you simply try to think these
things through on your own with your own
brain rather than relying on the script
you've been assigned if what I'm saying
offends you I don't care I'm just so
sick of this you know we try to have an
interesting intelligent conversation to
have somebody busting in with liberal
liberal pick a side geez
come on what a boring way to live too
I mean that really how you see
everything I don't know okay but thanks
for the email
finally - we have time probably now this
is a longer one all my emails are longer
ones so we will unfortunately have to
leave it on that on that on that note
alright by the way I don't know if
you've been following this impeachment
trial but it's only been a few days and
it's already pretty clear unsurprisingly
that the left and the media are going to
try to manipulate this and control the
way that people perceive what's
happening if you want to know the real
truth if you want a more unvarnished
take on what's happening and get behind
behind the scenes look into all of the
goings ons with the impeachment check
out the newly released podcast verdict
with Ted Cruz senator Ted Cruz and The
Daily wires own Michael Knowles take you
behind the scenes of the Capitol and
give you exclusive conservative insight
on the most important political stories
of the day people ask me all the time
you know what's going on with
impeachment what's the real story
because it could be hard to follow
especially when you can't trust the
sources that are telling you about it
well this show solves that problem join
senator Ted Cruz as he breaks down the
most important political stories of the
day on his new podcast verdict
it's a Nancy Pelosi house I think
they're interested in just non-stop
investigations and attack of the
president conservatives believe in power
to the people the socialists believe in
power to the government what they're
selling doesn't work subscribe today and
leave a five star review for verdict
with Ted Cruz co-hosted by me
Michael Knowles on Apple podcasts
Spotify and everywhere else you get your
podcasts be sure to check it out on
Apple podcast Spotify or whatever your
favorite streaming service is again
that's verdict with Ted Cruz
thanks everybody for listening PAML
included even the unit this is your last
time but thanks for being with us on
this journey at least for up until this
point and have a great weekend everybody
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there